now i can't get stupid butthole sun out
of my mouth
my brain hang on not my mouth my brain
my brain oh god no
i can't get stupid butthole son out of
my mouth
okay i'm readying up all right all right
i'm gonna nathan
uh hopefully i can change the music in
game because it is quite
quite thumpy here we go
usa 2006
california's coyote valley is blistering
under the summer sun
anna puerta leader of demonic local cult
the watchers of azazel has not been seen
for weeks after her succession in 2004
anna became obsessed with the idea of
summoning azel himself
for two years anna experimented with
rituals
found in ancient texts as she searched
for a way to raise the goat demon
the group fears that she has finally
achieved her goal
but with disastrous consequences
as one of her most trusted followers you
have arrived at anna's house
to find out what or who has gone wrong
couldn't come here the in the in the day
ooh oh hey
yeah all right go get your flashlight
hey guys i just say
anna [ __ ] up yeah why why is it a
zazel
why do we worship as hazel something
cool
i was saying this is a fan favorite i
was saying the same thing goat demon
kind of not really my
my jam hello fellow cultists hang on i
gotta i gotta train
my i'm sorry nathan hey nathan
i'm sam got it
what's your name buddy how could i just
say it like that like you don't know
your own name
oh no i just when my mom named me she
was very questioning of the name so my
my actual burst everything has the
question mark so my name is officially
sam
okay that's good no no no no no no
lag don't wag your finger you were
wagging your finger at me
all right hang on also it's running like
a turd this game my god
guys if you hold right click you get
spidey vision wait yeah you can actually
take flashlight
well if you look at the top right you
can see your uh little bar going down
oh good that doesn't oh yeah yeah oh it
doesn't oh okay thank god
it does okay it's still running kind of
poopy but let me just
hang on kill anna no wait what her she's
our leader we have to save her
leader yeah kill kill means something
different
to my uh people i have a cultural
heritage i haven't explained each other
you know what that's fair i will not
question your cultural heritage we have
no we don't have time to explain it anna
needs our help
to die all right cool you mean today
to die yes right now to die this guy
okay she needs to die today sounds good
to me oh you got sandals i like your
sandals
well it's part of the color sandals hey
look at this
well goat demon's dead we don't got to
worry about anything that's dead
cook it everyone aim your cooking
flashlights at it and we'll have dinner
maybe we should aim at its butthole all
right oh yeah that's where the that's
where you really want the uvs to go in
yeah yeah all right i'm outta here right
into the butthole it's really a shame we
didn't come out here during the day or
we'd really be able to channel our
powers
what's the button to lift the tail up i
want to make sure i'm getting it all the
way inside
well i mean uh uh it's p to peak all
right
it actually is i'm gonna be really
disappointed in you oh well
prepare for disappointment guys we got a
problem a lock
um melts it with our magic flashlights
[Music]
i feel like the flashlight doesn't do
what i wanted to do and i'm a little
yeah i think that you're kind of
misinterpreting this flashlight we got
from like best buy we didn't it's not
magical it buzzes like it's a taser is
it a taser flashlight come here
no uh no it it lets me teleport through
your body
that's cool okay
i've done it oh october 14th it wasn't
easy rounding up the goats for the
summoning ritual good thing i had so
much damned hay i'm starting to wonder
if it was a good idea to do this alone
nathan always told
me i should be with my people when the
time comes i feel strange like my skin
is burning
too much sun oh god damn hey before you
guys go that way
i don't understand yeah flower
collectible over here i think why what
do you what do you why did how did you
know this was here
how the hell is the man wearing the
magical custom
leather stitched robe knows something
that we don't know yeah that's kind of
weird
i'm just european looks kind of like a
mix between a blacksmith's
apron and a union soldier's uniform
that melted this is just a soldier boys
uniform
oh you got this from soldier store hey
guys there's a gas can over here
okay i got it right here
i found stuff too what else can you pick
up a bowl
wood hey a bunch of hay yeah a bunch of
hay
all right oh my god you it curls around
you
all right goat demons eat hay i assume
i'm assuming yeah here's you another
here's another flower
man you're good at finding these you're
really good at finding these
like you walk right to them no other
comments about that you're good at that
i'm just sam why would you say your name
like that
i never go i'm just oh i i already say
that he just
is i just sam you just say oh
sure okay you know i'm gonna stop
questioning it yeah yeah
uh oh he's making the same sound very
cute
somebody needs to get their dog hey i
found a flower look at me
i found one oh yeah you kind of just
went right forward yeah maybe i got some
weird knowledge that you guys don't huh
maybe anna was uh
my best friend hmm hey guys you're a
best friend
hey yeah yeah guys or best friend best
friends
do goats normally have glowing red eyes
well if they don't get enough uv light
in the butthole yeah
oh so they're they're just begging for
some buzzes yeah absolutely there you go
ghosts there goes
sound i need a cage key to do whatever i
was about to do to this thing but i
didn't do it
uh have that has anyone tried the you
know door yet
no and it really needs to be it's locked
this door here too is it locked also
locked
did anyone try the front door okay i'll
do it
you guys hear me through the house oh
yeah loud and clear right now
oh yeah you're quite loud yeah wow
almost like we didn't need this i know
that whenever i used proximity chat
before it was definitely not
from that far away i didn't heard you at
all guys i found a cracked window but i
can't do anything with it
well i found something back here my
gasoline in it and
uh light it on fire
maybe all right i'll try burning down
the house see if that gets us inside
all right sounds good man sounds good
does this sound any different down the
house
no okay no the light flashed is that
meaningful
i don't know i found a a another letter
this is
everything the watchers hoped for it's
almost time to sacrifice the goats and
it needs to be
me involving anyone else now could break
my bond with azazel
and then he would be banished why am i
shaking a dazzle
ass this is so disconcerting bob it
sounds like you're right next to us
this is the proximity inside my ear
balls
yeah that is weird but directional it is
directional a flower i found another
flower well what do you know
two for you two for me yeah bob what are
you doing guess what
i found another one right here oh oh
okay
uh right here on this hill where no
no right here oh right here
oh there there it is park i found it all
right good job bob
all right this is zazzle man there's one
more right here it's hitting this little
red bush how'd you know
i just saw it okay good let's check
very loud very loud when you grab them
oh somebody's littering out here are you
kidding me
yeah i saw that it's a damn shame uh
maybe we could get something to climb in
the broken window or something or maybe
we could break another window or maybe i
could break a window or maybe i could
break the walls break a window yeah
maybe i could break a window
well i'm just gonna keep going this way
this seems like the way
yeah you're probably right the game's
not let me walk anymore i don't think
this is the way
the game if you guys press k one of you
one of you pick up a key
key okay no the light flashed does that
mean
ah yeah yeah you know i remember that i
picked that up
i did get that that was that was me i
got that yeah i'm remembering now i got
that so
should i let the should i let the the
the poochies out
i did here they go
they disappeared for me whoa
this is strong goats i feel like they if
they had just worked together they could
have
done that to get out of their cage they
wanted to
hey i found a flower i found a flower
good job yeah i found it good job nicely
done
nicely done thank you so much this is a
pool room
that's pretty cool man anna was living
it up pizza i found a flower i found a
flower i found it
good job though that's good i found that
this is so cool there's no chill you
know anna never invited me over to play
pool
yeah like i didn't know that the cult
had like a hangout room
i i was never invited to hang out did
she ever feel left
out no no hey another letter
you guys want to hear it yes definitely
i can hear
a's ass azel's voice in my head
feel his rage in my veins i feel like
i'm losing control over him
i don't understand nut i can't stop the
strange words pouring from my mouth
as i speak them his minions are rising
all around me and
ooh the light go on that's it that was
it that was it oh hey i found a key
look here yep
sure i don't like the way you wave your
hay at me
yeah you know what's crazy guys i
totally have these shelving units i have
one of these in my garage
was the whole buzz the whole buzzer hole
does a hole buzz a hole
sam why aren't you chanting why don't
you ever chant with us oh i was i wasn't
holding t
you're on push to talk yeah mine was by
default already said i'm push to talk
but i thought we had to change over to
open
yeah i'm out of buzz i'm going upstairs
all right well i have a key that was
labeled
basement dude does it open this door
i don't
sam hey sam ah look at this yeah yeah
you're looking at my robe oh come on
keep opening the door come on
no oh wow hey knives
freezer get a better view of that guys
you know there's a time and a place to
look at my dump truck of an ass now
is not the time anna needs us anna's
dump truck
really well what's that red stuff at the
end of the hallway that's concerned
moving
is it whispering at us is it
scream whispering in us anna
anna i don't like that did anna have
like blowing red around her
neck and mouth ah you know maybe we
should
you guys want to go upstairs yeah you
know go down there yeah maybe not that
way got a lot of house to explore yeah
let's go up
sienna that could be anything that could
be hey i found a flower
that's great found a flower nice nice
man nice good
this door is live that's locked
upstairs yeah that was good we got that
taken care of your flashlight's all
funky yeah flashlight's not going so
[ __ ] very well
hey the buzz works
i'll go you know what i'll talk to her
okay cool nice
good we've got a connection yeah yeah
hey anna hey it's all
hey here we go right
stand right here where i am and you'll
understand what's happening a little
more clearly oh yeah oh yeah look at the
goat
hey look at this wow look at the goat
paint they do like goats
they don't like good wallpaper there's
really ugly wallpaper hey anna is right
there
um what if i just go
in this room to the left oh
okay that's locked oh oh
okay when you got a goat you gotta go
yeah no it sounded like she was having
some
some tummy troubles you know ah anna do
you know where the doors are
oh the door's open now or some some
imodium
i can go to the first screen dude get
the standard right now
first aid oh yes absolutely
okay all right everyone come with me and
help anna well we'll check out here
first wait
what's up hey come on now take a peek
take a peek right there take a peek
oh oh my god hey i found a flower
oh good job nice find nice nice man and
it really needs to clean her knives
after she's done using them
well i mean anna's kind of a slob we all
know this hey key
office key hey i know where that is yeah
what's the sound is that the ceiling fan
i think he's a ceiling fan oh yeah that
is the tiniest ceiling fan i've ever
hannah needs to do some updates yeah you
know budgets
budget cuts who else you're slamming no
occasional thump i hear something
thumping yeah i feel like i'm hearing
slamming
i do not hear something hey there's
another first aid kit over here i
grabbed one myself so i'm good
we probably know okay we you know
there's something weird going on here
who uses an abacus who uses an abacus
oh no hey sam god yeah
sorry i just wanted to just wander
through hey i found a flower you can't
just
wander through doors like that that was
surprising
that was the most casual saunter in i've
ever witnessed
anyway maybe the abacus is a decoration
there's no way that's what's an abacus
use i don't know what an abacus is
typically used for that is a calculator
good luck trying to figure out how yeah
oh i just thought it was always like a
kid's toy or something
i mean yeah navicus is one of those kids
toy with a bunch of blocks on rails you
just slide them back and forth
that's why old philosophers just kept
them around it's like those old
candy necklaces you could wear yeah yeah
like bite off the candy
yeah yeah yeah yeah invented in the late
1910s by john richard abacus
yep uh basically just a little
meaningless trinket not useful
this house is bigger than i thought it
would be gotta be honest
look at this lovely succulent oh wait
you have an office
hey i found a flower oh nice find oh
yeah
right i do yes the office is over um
found a letter i found anna october
question they seem to fear delight
i'm trying to stop them guys
get the first aid kit said anna in the
kitchen in the dining area
oh god yeah go wait get it
she's healing wait go wait
uh
sorry i forgot that i had a first aid
kit anna yeah anna
oh okay okay so freaky this is anna
forgive you for what
[Music]
don't worry mark i'm coming with you
okay i'll protect
you where'd you go oh okay
you seem okay how do i help you uh i
don't know you need a first aid kit
oh hey anna so
well anna that's kind of rude friends
treat
friends that's kind of rude i gotta be
honest like i know
i've known we know anna i know she's
tall
she's taller than i remember does
becoming a demon make you
like do like that girl from uh willy
wonka where you stretch out
yeah i think it's like yeah i think you
just kind of no no that's okay
hold on can't hold on she seems to be
interested in you sam
oh that's not good she's got very uh
small feet compared to her oh there she
goes
oh oh oh plus the anna
after each goat burned uv light does not
work when her eyes are red well that's
weird oh it's not
so you have the key to the office yeah i
got the key to the is this the office
so yeah the office is this door yeah oh
there's another key in here
attic wow wow what does this do
another key dude i'm keen
burn it i i tried i buzzed it nothing
happened burn the goat
it's not working and we got alerts oh hi
anna maybe we gotta lure it somewhere
and uh
like use the hay to lure it and gasoline
pour all over it and then light up
oh mark look at this there's an atari in
here
where where are you it's an atari with
the games the uncertain
and zeath sector i love zeath sector
whoa hey are those are those real games
or spoofs of games that's the question
man i don't know oh there's another game
over here what is this
oh bob i know it's your job but i found
a flower up here
i found that we haven't done that i just
didn't say anything we haven't heard
wade in a while
[Music]
you